who made this oh I did wow I'm gonna cry
it's a masterpiece that should get an
Emmy that should get a Tony all of it
and that still wouldn't be enough for
what that was
[Music]
[Applause]
Chef wonderful here let's talk about
suffolakia you know what that is it's a
sandwich a sandwich I learned all about
it when I was a teenager living on the
island of Cyprus Nicosia Cyprus the
capital I went to a British boarding
school for many years and this is what
we had every day for lunch I fell in
love with it now you may want to ask
yourself something but wait before we
start oh just a Shameless promotion to
O'Leary Chardonnay did I tell you I won
five awards for this
yeah I did yeah but it's fantastic sure
and you can get it at qvc.com I know I
know Shameless promotion but let me have
a sip
hmm
fantastic so you know these stories
about the Mediterranean diet the
Mediterranean lifestyle Mediterranean
foods
well it's true because
people live to their over 100 years old
on these islands why why do they live so
long diet exercise no question about
lifestyle less stress they walk
everywhere
we're talking about three thousand four
thousand five thousand six thousand
steps before nine o'clock in the morning
Twenty Thousand Steps all day long
that's what we're talking up and down
the mountains but it's the food they eat
the veggies all the healthy stuff
lamb Port beef chicken
no hormones we're talking about Island
raised but the point is I want to go
back to this sandwich we're going to try
a Super Lucky sandwich pita bread is
involved we're going to get that later
all these amazing vegetables fantastic
virgin olive oils now the thing about
Virgin Olive Oil what does that mean it
means the olive never went out on a date
off the tree never dated straight in oil
yeah it's tragic but sacrificed its life
without ever dating for a fantastic very
healthy oil which is very much part of
what we're going to do here today so
we're going to start with these pork
cutlets now if you don't eat pork for
whatever reason I understand you can
substitute chicken okay but the classic
suffolakia
sandwich is made with pork and lots of
fat on a skewer barbecued then put into
the sandwich with lots of interesting
ingredients you know another sip of
shard
[Music]
oh yes that's good oh my goodness that's
crazy okay let's get to work
the only reason I Mr Wonderful have time
to search for the rare Vermillion
flycatcher is because my companies have
already received money from the employee
retention credit program go to
wondertrust.com to see if your business
qualifies today
[Music]
so
what do I have here
poor cutlets
I've said this many times don't be a
dork put pork on your fork
pork is a very healthy white meat
there's no reason not to eat unless you
have reasons you can't and I get it
however for this dish we're going to
enjoy some pork on our Fork we're going
to cube it to prepare it for the skewer
then we're going to marinate it I'm
going to show you how to make the
marinade which is very very important
doesn't have to be in that long we want
the moisture the juice to make it just
perfect so we're going to take our blade
we're looking for sort of one inch cubes
all right you're going to go to work on
it
make these cubes because you've got to
remember you're going to be making these
cubes for the sandwich so you're going
to be putting them in and people want
bite size they want to be able to eat
them so they're not too big so the three
quarter by three quarter cubes is the
way to go
there's a Harmony in making it and
you're keeping the fat because you can
put those between the actual cubes of
pork all right you want tender pork
tender pork on your fork let's put them
in here while we're waiting because
we're going to marinate them keeping the
fat is available because we're going to
be using it between because we want the
fat to burn on the BBQ to give it that
flavor perfect there we go by the way
watch your dexters always want you know
what I say about cooking people say to
me oh Chef wonderful why don't you ever
cut your fingers because I'm watching
what I'm doing that's why keep your eye
on the blade all the time
chefs cut their fingers off when they're
not watching what they're doing you
never see me talking the camera when I'm
cutting through something I'm stroking
forward but I'm keeping my eye on the
blade all the time otherwise bad things
can happen you don't want that take it
from Chef wonderful all right back to
what I was saying notice the eyes to the
blade so stroke forward makes the cut we
said three quarter keeping my eye on the
blade making the cut yes indeed always
watching the blade in action
into the bowl
that's not so hard right and it's Safety
First
well absolutely oh
Chardonnay break
oh that's good
so five awards for The Shard on Oak
Shard beautiful where can you get a
qvc.com and we include shipping at 11
bucks a bottle
fantastic I've got Pinot I've got cab
but today because we're pre-cooking it's
a beautiful day outside we're enjoying a
little Chardonnay exactly
you can also think about Chardonnay as
America's wife because we make it Sonoma
Napa fantastic remember back to the
blade keeping my eye on it stroking
forward beautiful cutting the pork
because it'll be on the fork and keeping
the fat not discarding the fat because
we're thinking ahead so when we're going
to barbecue it we want that fat to melt
and give us that Smoky flavor that we're
going to be looking for on the pork on
the skewer
you see cutting just perfectly into
those little cubes now remember you're
going to shrink this pork even though
it's not that fatty by about 20 so you
want that bite size so these that's a
perfect size like that's a perfect size
right there see that's gonna it's gonna
shrink 20 so don't worry about it why do
I know that because I've done this a
thousand times before I'm giving you the
superlakia secret the secret of the
sufalakia sandwich by the way what's so
great about this you can make this
prepare the pork early leave in the
fridge for three to four days guests
come over you can whip up a beautiful
sandwich in two seconds
the kids love this the neighbors love it
everybody's always asks me oh can I have
a superlakia well no kidding it's
fantastic
here we go
I always think about ingredients as
being in a conversation if they're too
small they don't get to be part of it if
they're too big they're arrogant and
insolent but if they're just the right
size they can be really enjoyed by
others you can use pork chops you want
to cut it off the bone you want some fat
and some tenderness talk to your butcher
wherever you get or get pork cutlets
from the grocery store try and make them
at least three quarters of an inch thick
so what are the ingredients to marinate
the pork to give it the extra juice the
juice that you want by the way we're
going to be getting into some cukes
later I always say with cukes
people buy these big cucumbers no don't
do that they're not crunchy
mmm
you want small cukes they give you the
texture however you're talking about
first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to start with some virgin
olive oil all right
you can find virgin olive oil in many
places
remember
these are olives that never went on a
date from the tree right to the oil
they sacrificed their whole
relationships
no dates imagine they're just pining to
get off the tree to meet another olive
no right in the bottle
a moment of silence
[Music]
to respect them
a virgin olive oil is made from Virgin
olives they never dated okay so we have
it so we're taking some
onto the
putting liberal be liberal you're
putting the olive oil onto the pork came
off before it went on the floor got it
now here's the secret this is the secret
of all Mediterranean life
you know why
lemon trees grow everywhere in Cypress
everybody has lemon trees in their
backyard they don't pay for lemons they
have them for free more lemons than you
could throw a stick at every day there's
just walk outside grab a lemon that's
how it works that's what lemon is all
about
it's the essence of life it extends your
life
um
now can't do that in North America make
sure you get big beautiful ripe lemon
all right you're going to cut your lemon
in half don't worry about if it has
seeds in it people know what seeds look
like you're gonna squeeze it right into
the marinade all right there you're
doing it you're squeezing the juice
right in here you're gonna do maybe
three of these just with your hands feel
and smell that Citrus oil just beautiful
ah that reminds me of the oceans lapping
on the rocks in Carina Harbor in Cyprus
yeah beautiful absolutely beautiful this
is this is what cooking is all about
bring back those memories okay another
lemon that's not enough you really want
this Citrus to be part of the story on
this marinade okay because you put in
the fridge overnight if you want we
don't have to do that now but I'm just
giving you the secret of how we're going
to do this
so two lemon
in here there's no magic to this how
much lemon juice but you really want it
out there you want it on here because
it's going to come in again as part of
this story all right there we have it
the Lemo all right now
yes kosher salt I happen to like that
just a tad you don't need too much you
don't need too much
fresh ground pepper may we
get it right there
perfect
that I'm talking about be liberal
and then
the Mediterranean Secret
let's show people
just go crazy for so many people go
crazy for but they don't know what it is
zatar what is zartar so I thought was a
Mediterranean spice thousands of years
old Sesame seeds baked and crushed
my mother taught me this this is the
secret of everything
I love zatar
no it's not a pepper it's sesame seeds
it just makes everything
me
perfect now we've got the juice we have
the meat we have the zatar the salt the
pepper
we're liberal we're putting it out there
that's correct we want to make sure the
meat is basically marinated so it can
have some moisture to it just a little
secret all the street vendors who make
suffolakia and Nicosia Cyprus have their
own Secrets they don't disclose I'm
disclosing because I want you to try
this you can't believe how good this is
you cannot believe how good this is so
you got to go to work you got to get
your skewers up
you don't want to you can't pan fry this
you'll have to put it on a skewer now
you also with skewers you want to make
sure you don't zap yourself you've got
to be careful you put a little fat on
there too keep your fingers out of the
way so you can do it by just poking down
first and then pushing on the edges of
the meat do not skewer yourself all you
know you've got to be careful you get
over time you'll learn how to do this
but you know there's no there's just the
meat and the fat on this because we want
to cook it in a way that gets it smoked
that's the key all right so I'm putting
on liberal amounts of fat because I know
that's going to burn and drip that's
perfect look here's a big slab of fat no
problem
because that'll smoke the meat beside it
very important part of a cypriot secret
you see that's about enough see that
it's about enough about 10 inches nine
inches so that's one put on the plate
over here
and then we're going to go for the next
one I was telling my wife earlier we're
going to make sofalaki she said oh I
love it I love it what a great summer
you know dinner yeah absolutely that's
what I feel like doing and I wanted to
share it with you I haven't done this
before with you but I make this all the
time you know there's a certain Zen to
cooking I've said this so many times you
get in the groove the minutes go by your
mind is consumed with making great food
for friends and family I mean I highly
recommend this if you have a stressed
out job and you're doing like you know
I'm thinking about
finance and business and Deals and all
the stuff and then I think about cooking
what I'm saying is there's a balance
there's a Zen there's a ying and there's
a yay
the chaos the Artistry of cooking of the
dexterity and all that oil and butter
sugar flour you know lemon all the stuff
you're working with
these are ancient primordial
the basics of food nothing to do with
the balance sheet at all but I think it
makes you a better businessman if you
can actually do both you get the
Artistry you get the Zen you get the
calming effect your Saturday afternoon
you're skewering fat pork fat on a
skewer why not why don't you do that
like why just worry about money all the
time you don't have to if you don't
worry about it all day you'll make more
that's my theory okay you've got to have
the balance when you're doing the
skewers by the way leave enough room so
it Cooks on the edges because you're
going to Brown those edges that's the
key
all right we're gonna get probably two
more out of this and then we're gonna
hit the grill the good really
and that's the art of keeping your eye
you know people do not spend enough time
close to the barbecue now you can do
this with charcoal I've done that many
times but tonight we're going to use a
grill outside that I've already got
stoked up
perfect
art right there piece of art so what do
we got well we got one two three four
five six so that's enough for six
sandwiches we're gonna serve six people
if we wanted to
and we can also store them oh the zatar
a little secret here you know what I'm
going to do throw a little bit of saltar
just before I dependent yeah baby just a
little bit extra there
I'll tell you a little secret too
um I don't know if you know this one
meldon sea salt huge salt crystals now I
don't endorse this because I want too
much salt to my food but they're so big
and the seeds sneak on a little bit of
this just a little bit they'll fall off
during the grilling but everybody's got
their own little thing and that's a
friend of mine gave me that secret and I
really liked it I did it on steak it was
fantastic
away for now I don't want it to go stale
keep it out of the air
remember it's sesame seeds little sip of
Chardonnay
okay let's go to the grill
so
putting them beside each other we're
going to be rotating a lot
see that putting it beside each other
that's the key
oh beautiful oh my goodness yeah it's
gonna stick the grill a bit but there's
so much olive oil on it you don't have
to worry about it too much you know get
a spatula to make it easier for us
[Music]
this room is half indoors half outdoor
screens with a beautiful view of the
lake if you look right over there
look at that isn't that fantastic what a
great place to cook a little sofalakia
yeah baby
great many many memories at this dining
room table
okay here we go so
that's perfect
lift it off rotate it same for the oh my
goodness that cue is hot and it's good
right there
perfect perfect
[Music]
so I'm talking about superlakia right
there so you want you want that you see
what I'm talking about there that little
Chris Bay that little it's burning a
little not burning but it's getting
browned out that's what you want you
want that all around the edges of the
pork that gives it the personality
you're going to need in the sandwich
you're gonna want that and it's going to
shrink it's shrinking even as we speak
these little guys are shrinking as we
speak
[Music]
perfect perfect perfect
yes see the fat is burning giving it the
flavor that's what we're looking for
this is all about the Mediterranean
lifestyle eating great food great
vegetables olive oil
beautiful wines walking every day
still after 109. what's wrong with that
this guy look at that
he's cooked
this guy's the only guy that needs a
little bit more last
hanger on
[Music]
and we are absolutely finished
hear that fan Stoke up
look at that baby oh yeah oh yeah we're
ready to make the suffolakia sandwich
I'm Mr Wonderful and I'm bird watching
the only reason I have time to search
for the rare Vermillion flycatcher is
because my companies have already
received money from the employee
retention credit program filing for that
money takes a lot of time time I'd
rather spend doing what I love like
waiting for a glimpse of a red-legged
honey creeper gotcha buddy so do what I
did go to wondertrust.com to see if your
business qualifies for up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee we've got
the souffleck on a skewer
we've got the vegetables we've got the
olives so the whole idea of Souvlaki
sandwiches blending together
great pork in a sandwich with pita so
the way you're going to do this with
Peter pita bread standard Mediterranean
I'm gonna cut it in half make a pita
pocket
see that
very important I'm going to put in
various everybody has their own Theory
what they're going to put in here let me
tell you we're going to put in today
we're going to put in some lettuce we're
going to put in some cukes you want
small cukes not big juice you want the
crunch you take the tips off each end
you have the Cuke watching your dexters
again right you get half Moons
just like that throw it in the sandwich
now you want a radish
big juicy radish Mediterranean radish
okay
gives you color gives you texture gives
you flavor
don't make it too big you have some
radish
little half Moons again you want bite
size right see that what I'm doing so a
little radish action
into the pita pocket tomato is an
absolute necessity but you want a tomato
with texture
it's not going to fall apart so you're
smaller tomat is the way to go into
cubes take the
take the ends off of course
you know you can get all kinds of
different Tomatoes well look what I'm
doing here look how it stays together
and then I'm doing little Demi moons
watch this
cubes
Cube it out baby Cube it out
it's all matte
the Artistry ready
parsley wash your parsley first as I've
done
you can get
all kinds of different parsleys I'm
using parsley so important that I'm
using two different varietals
but
see that I'm really chopping it up
lightly
punch and crunch
oh that Mediterranean oh my goodness a
little so just a sprinkling of parsley
in there yeah baby and then I'm also
going to do a little curly parsley
stop the madness look at this I want the
extra texture
[Laughter]
in it goes into the pita we're not done
yet though because we need the pork
perfect
I've cooked it perfectly so you take the
pork off skewer
with the fat everything's coming off
it's got that see that
you can put this on the top of the
sandwich you're having a lemon ready and
you'll tell you why in a second
okay so what we're going to do is we're
taking the pita pocket
we're putting little chunks of pork on
the top
just like that
you want the crunch a little fat in
there a little parsley
and then
yeah you got it the secret of zatar
the ancient Mediterranean spice that my
mother taught me about which I put a
little bit right on top
on her piece of pork
then
this is the real secret just before you
take the first bite put on a little
lemon
right off the fresh lemon right off the
garden right out of the garden you
squeezing on like that we should do this
every day just before we went back to
class a little lemon juice right on top
a little parsley on there
oh my God and you ready you ready here
we go
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa who made this
oh I did whoa I'm gonna cry it's a
masterpiece it's a masterpiece are you
kidding are you freaking kidding that is
the best cephalakia
anybody's ever rigged
I mean I don't want to take credit for
it I think a higher force was involved
you know the famous waves from Cyprus
got involved in making this there has to
be there's no way this is not a human
sandwich this came from
outer space this is ridiculously good
stop the madness
do exactly what I did to make the
sandwich don't change anything whatever
I did to make this sandwich
it's perfect don't mess with it do
exactly when I put the salt on or the
zotron do the exact same thing it does
not get better
than what we just ate and that
is how you make a soufflecki sandwich
my friends
please enjoy